the Joe Rogan experience why is it that
so many team guys wind up getting into
skydiving BASE jumping parachutes what
is that funny [ __ ] is that what it is I
can love it
is it there's a thing I mean I don't
want to speak for you but some men up
the the highs and the thrills of that
stuff of BASE jumping and look what is
it that's so attractive about that I
don't know as much of if it's the thrill
as the thrill combined with the enormous
amount of mental effort and cognitive
load that's going on and focus because
you know the consequences [ __ ] yeah
mmm like if you're on the edge of a
cliff in a wingsuit there's so much [ __ ]
that can go wrong between the second you
push off that thing and you can't turn
around to this 60-ish seconds that it
takes to get to the ground boom that has
killed a lot of people a lot of people a
lot of people yeah how many times you
wingsuit jump a couple hundred bucks and
I have about 700 BASE jumps Wow is that
a good thing for veterans when they come
back as well just to give them something
that allows them to feel that edge again
I would never suggest somebody learn to
base jump really [ __ ] no I don't even
call it a sport I call it a life choice
so you only want people to do it that
are drawn to it yeah if you're a person
is so willing to do that thing that you
will do anything it takes to make it
happen and go around me to learn how to
do it okay that okay but I'm not gonna
be like it's a great choice for you yeah
oh don't go to therapy you should jump
off a cliff
how much can therapy help veterans I
always feel like you either have the
ability to handle [ __ ] or you don't and
then they can help you if you have the
ability to handle [ __ ] I agree does that
make is that it does that's a arrogant
assumption on my part from no experience
but
the way I'm thinking of it it's like the
amount of wrestling that must be done in
your mind going from combat deployment
to regular Society and seeing the the
petty [ __ ] that people think of as
being like life or death or real real
issues and needs screaming and fighting
and you're like you [ __ ] babies ya
know and you see that a lot with guys
that come back is they're just like the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
yeah is this really worth it right and
but I do think that therapy of some type
archery technical shooting BASE jumping
jujitsu there are things that you can
take up that I think help guys unpack at
eyes like undo all of the [ __ ] that's in
their head mmm you don't have to go to a
therapist to talk doesn't happen that's
not necessarily the best thing for
everybody there's a weird thing about
the mind right where it has to be active
yeah you have to give your mind tasks oh
yeah yike even meditating isn't being
task less right right right you're
focusing on focusing yes there's
something there there's something going
on yeah that gray matter is doing some
work you got to get the engine turning
yeah it's and also it's like for people
that have experienced combat deployments
and then they come back to regular life
it's almost like your body's accustomed
to a certain level of stress and now
it's not there anymore so it might start
creating it on its own or looking for it
when it's not there oh yeah and and I
think Andy's joked about it I have no
idea I haven't been tested nor has he if
I know but you know so many of us are
like adrenal fatigue because we're just
wound the [ __ ] up at fifth gear for
years right
is that real adrenal fatigue I think so
yeah you know what I mean a lot of guys
are very just like me about so much
right and I don't think that that's
because they don't care I think it's
because their their hormones are out of
whack that makes sense
well there's also a lot of guys whose
hormones are out of whack
you know from IEDs and from
blowing down doors okay
I've been dumped enough where like I
felt my teeth you know I'm pretty sure
you're not supposed to be able to feel
your teeth yeah Jesus Christ well so
many guys who get back have hormone
issues too because that pituitary gland
damage from chronic chronic brain trauma
I'm not surprised
yeah and that stuff that really needs to
be addressed and that's the kind of
stuff like you were saying for the
charity for the traumatic brain injury
mm-hmm that's [ __ ] that needs to get
looked at yeah we need to be doing
preventative work yes like ahead of time
yes and then monitoring people making
sure that they're okay
because that stuff is degenerative and
people need to know that that's out
there and it can be helped is it hard
sometimes for veterans to ask for help I
think so because they just feel like
maybe asking shows a weakness or maybe
they just it's just too difficult to
reach out I think I think it's the too
difficult to reach out and I don't want
to be the problem or there must be guys
that are worse than me I think it's
usually that it's not necessarily the
the fully inflated ego of I'm just gonna
be a hard-ass but less which it there is
you know that's out there but I think
it's a lot of guys that are like now
there's probably somebody worse than me
right so if you come home and you're not
traumatically injured right we know legs
blown off or arm blown off you feel like
you're lucky so you feel maybe like you
shouldn't be asking for help other
people need help more like I don't need
that seat at the table let me go find
somebody else for it that the lack of
support when veterans return is really
disturbing like the idea that there's so
much emphasis put into training there's
so much emphasis put into arming and and
making sure that everybody is geared up
you're a multi-million dollar machine
yeah but then when you get back they
don't have a use for anymore your used
tire [ __ ] now it's getting better and a
lot of the outside groups do a really
good job but it's tough to realize that
there's outside groups that are doing
that job yes a lot of its guys like
what's the Fed doing right right thanks
guys
it's almost like there's no pressure on
them to resolve some of these issues or
to help when you come back is there any
coaching do they give you any sort of
advice um I didn't end up going to any
of that and they always tell you hey if
you need to talk to somebody there are
people to talk to you and other people
that you talk to
are they psychologists or they combat
veterans as well or psychologists mmm
which i think is a good thing it's a
good thing to talk to psychologists I
think so are any of those guys veterans
themselves they're from my recollection
they're all in the military they're all
in the military but are they all did
they experience action I'm not sure I
don't want to say out like offhand
without knowing for certain I didn't end
up talking to any of them so I don't
know do you
like is this something that you discuss
with team leaders or like guys have been
who have deployed and they've returned
is this like a common thing where you go
hey you know what's it like when you get
back is it how hard is it to transition
to normal everyday life and keep your
[ __ ] together and what are the tools
that you use to try to maintain I think
unfortunately that's the stuff that's
getting talked about now just now yeah
yeah and more recently because so many I
mean it makes sense are you gonna like
like with fighters right do they ask
each other how do you recover after a
fight no it's how do you prep for it
make sure you win right because that's
all we care about when we're looking at
front end right front end an action
front end action front end action how do
I train how do I mitigate all the risk
how do I make sure that my buddy isn't
the one that's killed because I [ __ ] up
right right yeah so if that's what we're
concerned about nobody gives to crap
about what's going on with back end
because you're just gonna rinse wash
repeat that cycle right till you're done
[Applause]